Welcome to the program.
We have seen enough Joseph Biden Jr. will
be the president elect of the United States,
defeating Donald Trump.
The race has been called by Decision Desk
HQ.
Others are starting to call the race.
Individuals familiar with particular states
are making it clear that in those states,
there will be no turning back, that Joe Biden's
leads, including new found leads that appeared
overnight, will sustain.
And at this point in time, we are not saying
Donald Trump will concede anything.
There is no doubt whatsoever that Donald Trump
is going to be filing lawsuits and trying
to get recounts and there will be some recounts.
But because Joe Biden has taken leads now
in multiple states and leads have grown in
other states, Joe Biden is poised to be the
presumptive winner of the presidential race.
And we can say that with some comfort at this
point in time.
So let's take a look at some of the numbers,
the latest numbers in the key uncalled states.
Reminder, Alaska is still not called.
It will not matter in the end.
In Nevada, as the vote has continued to trickle
in from 75 to 80, 85 now 86 percent reporting
at the last batch of votes, Joe Biden's lead
growing by a few more votes now to 21, 20
and a half thousand votes in Nevada.
There is every indication based on the overwhelming
amount of votes left from the Las Vegas area,
which votes for Joe Biden, that the lead will
grow.
That alone would be enough to get Joseph R.
Biden Jr. to 270 electoral votes in Arizona.
The vote continues to come in and there is
no credible path for Donald Trump to retake
the lead.
Remember that Arizona was called by both the
Associated Press and Fox News a couple of
days ago.
Donald Trump insisting they should keep counting
the votes.
Of course, that's what we do in elections.
We keep counting the votes and they've continued
to count the votes.
And that does not appear as though that will
be reversed.
Pennsylvania overnight flipping from Donald
Trump to Joe Biden.
It started two days ago as an eight point
lead for Trump, they knew the mail and votes
would be counted over time.
And as that happened, the lead for Joe Biden
shrank.
I'm sorry, the lead for Donald Trump shrank
from eight to seven, six, five, four, three,
two.
Last night, it went below one.
It went to below half a point.
This morning, it was tied.
And with the latest addition of votes, Joe
Biden has now taken a lead of about nine thousand
eighty nine hundred votes in Pennsylvania
because of what is left to count.
Experts in Pennsylvania say there is no path
for Donald Trump to retake that lead.
In Georgia, Donald Trump has lost his lead,
slowly diminishing from a few points to half
a point to a tie as of right now, statistically
forty nine point four for each candidate.
Although when you go one more digit, you see
that Joe Biden does have a slight lead there
of about 800 votes.
And so any combination understand that Nevada
alone does it for Joe Biden.
Nevada experts say Nevada is done, but were
he not to get Nevada and even if he were to
lose Arizona, Pennsylvania alone would put
Joe Biden over 270.
This makes North Carolina, which has not gone
either way yet, irrelevant, essentially.
Of course, if Joe Biden maintains Georgia,
he also wins.
If he gets Georgia, but not Pennsylvania,
he needs certainly to maintain Arizona or
Nevada.
And of course, if things end as they are now,
we don't know if they will.
But if they do, Joe Biden will end up with
three hundred and six electoral votes, more
electoral votes than Donald Trump had in 2016
and a massive, absolutely massive popular
vote victory.
As of right now, the popular vote is in Joe
Biden's favor by two point seven percent,
which, because of the very high turnout, is
nearly four million votes, just shy of that
at about two point nine six million votes
right now, just shy of that four three point
nine six, rather, just shy of a four million
vote margin.
It will be a historic popular vote margin
for Joseph R. Biden Jr..
One last sort of element to look at the current
count per The New York Times in Pennsylvania,
matching up with that of the Associated Press,
a slight Joe Biden lead in Georgia, a very
slight Joe Biden lead in North Carolina, still
with no new reporting.
And we are not expecting any new reporting
for some time.
Has Joe Biden down one point four percentage
points, but we do not expect it to matter.
Arizona, The New York Times has not called,
but the numbers remaining in Joe Biden's favor.
And then again, as I mentioned in Nevada with
the latest update, Joe Biden now with a 20
or so thousand vote lead there.
So, ladies and gentlemen, it is happening.
It is happening now.
We are not out of the woods in the sense of
we still don't have Senate results.
We still don't know what's going on with the
House.
In total, Donald Trump will get recounts in
some states.
He's filing lawsuits.
In some states, he has gone completely out
of his mind and he is unlikely to concede.
Insiders are saying Trump will not concede.
Now, don't worry, because concession is not
a legal process.
Concession is a formality where normal people,
when they lose, say, I concede my opponent
has won.
They call their opponent.
In ideal times, you issue a message of unity.
Not that I liked these people, but John McCain
in 2008 had to silence the boos from his sycophants
to say Barack Obama is a good man.
We both love this country.
We are with Barack Obama.
George H.W. Bush, when he lost in 1992 to
Governor Bill Clinton, is showing again.
Doesn't mean we're saying he's a great was
a great president.
He wasn't, but he behaved like a normal person.
He behaved like a normal person.
Even Hillary Clinton in 2016, despite Donald
Trump saying you would be in jail if I was
president, conceded despite Donald Trump's
claims to the contrary.
So we are going to be paying very close attention
over the next few days to whether there is
violence, to how the vote counts.
Continue coming in on today's program, we
will be speaking about everything from Sean
Hannity saying they need to redo the Pennsylvania.
Election Trump adviser Stephen Bannon saying
Dr. Anthony Fauci should be beheaded, yes,
yes, he said that and so much more.
But the big news is the presumptive we are
not yet saying president elect, the presumptive
winner of the 2020 presidential election is
Joe Biden.
Now, in advance of what I know will be some
disappointment that Biden didn't win by more
and that the Senate and House aren't looking
great, we are going to talk about the problems
on the left that led to what should have been
a blowout, not being a blowout.
But it's not just the left.
It's also the right.
There is a lot to discuss and I don't want
to shortchange that conversation.
So let's not do it right now.
But what I do want to remind people is.
This is the removal of an incumbent president,
it is very difficult to remove an incumbent
president.
Bill Clinton did it to George H.W. Bush in
1992.
That was a three way race.
Ross Perot was in that one.
There were additional factors, complexities,
cetera.
It is not common that you remove even a bad
incumbent president.
So we have to remember, when we look at the
numbers, incumbent president loses by four
million.
That is a big deal.
It doesn't excuse the failings of the Democratic
Party.
It does nothing.
It doesn't excuse the fact that nearly 70
million, Trump said, let me vote for four
more years of that.
That's horrifyingly scary.
But the important thing to remember is that
removing an incumbent president is really
difficult.
I expect we will see more calls by the networks
over the next few hours.
Donald Trump did speak yesterday and we're
going to have video of that.
He gave a completely delusional, humiliating
press briefing saying everything is fake,
everything is fraud, claiming victory.
Donald Trump Jr. took to Twitter and said
that they need to go into total war mode,
which I'm worried will lead to violence.
We had questions throughout the day yesterday.
Why does Trump want to stop counting states
that he's losing?
If you stop counting when you're losing, you
lose.
We will find out about the incompetence that
was at play there.
And we are even starting to see some Republicans.
And I'm not saying they're good people because
they're not.
But some some Republicans are even jumping
ship with Trump's authoritarianism, saying
it's dangerous for him to claim victory when
he hasn't.
It's dangerous for him to claim fraud when
he has not presented any actual evidence of
fraud.
And because we want to have more good news
today, if possible, I will talk about the
very bad news about the pandemic.
I will tell you about that.
One hundred and eighteen thousand cases yesterday.
But on the good news, the war on drugs was
absolutely crushed, crushed on Election Day.
Very interesting numbers.
2016 was not a fluke.
Donald Trump and his coalition are still here
and they are very strong, they almost got
him reelected.
But Joseph R. Biden Jr. with multiple paths
to 270 and now we can say the presumptive
winner.
The race has been called by Decision Desk
HQ.
And I anticipate more calls very, very soon.
So glad you're with me.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.